me
wait what's wrong what's [__] with your
nose
it's leaking a little bit Morehead
pickle
oh [__] yeah
that's crazy
what is this crickets is this Fear
Factor yeah
hi it's Joe Rogan
[Music]
nice spread dude yeah this is a
beautiful spread what what's the
occasion uh we need something to talk
about I hope he did a field trip
yesterday and
to wear
Carolyn you can get crickets at arawan
no there's no [__] way you can get
the Warhead pickle at arawan yeah Cody
would know
I actually I actually would know yeah I
go there pretty often
sadly oh nice the one chip challenge
yeah I'll watch you do that yeah that
one's for you not for no yeah no but if
you want to get the rest of the [__] in
your nose yeah that's true yeah that's
perfect for you honestly are you sick
nah I get a bad fever there's a bad
fever
just a bad fever at all just super bad
fever nah I always get this just like
throat [__] throat [__] yeah
I just gotta like spit out a bunch of
um
yummy I'm a spitter nice kind of
bloodshot too yeah I think I part of the
blood vessel
taking a [__] or what yeah
yeah well it looks pretty hardcore
thanks dude I've been a war
uh what's this for
what kind of drinks we got here secrets
she covered they're all taped up yeah so
we'll have to reveal it and uh what's
this uh charcuterie here what do we got
sort of meat log here
what is this
Opie what is that
fancy salami
that really looks like a dog toy
it tastes like one
that's not salami it's like fake what it
tastes like honey it has like olives and
figs and stuff like that it's a
disgusting
that board's supposed to be good get
some
what is this cracker
just a cracker
I know it's a cracker you [__]
[__]
you guys act like I haven't been around
the world before
it's not it's not a cracker it's Krakow
I think it's a branzino
so I got my Branzino got that [__]
burned in my head dude why why just the
way she said it all right that was like
like subliminal messaging I don't even
think that was a story it was just her
just repeatedly going
I have my Branzino so I got the Branzino
and then so then I got the Branzino it's
like that's the only thing you're
supposed to know I think the whole thing
is a [__] op to get you to go to that
restaurant
oh Gorilla Marketing deep gorilla Morgan
wow it's kind of like the schmungus
thing yeah same sort of thing yeah
the restaurant where the girl got the
brands you know it is it is yeah do you
have any brands that we're all out
yeah thanks to tick tock look this place
[__] packed
now they got a line around the block
everyone's trying to get the [__]
Brands you know people were making
shirts yeah every food reviewer on Tech
talk so I got the famous Branzino here
in front of me
Keith Lee yeah Keith Lee yeah did not
realize it was Kevin Lee's brother
who who's Kevin Lee oh he's a fighter he
was a fighter in the UFC oh and then
Keith Lee fought in the UFC really I
don't know he fought MMA I don't think
he fought in the UFC oh wow he found
Bellator oh cool and now he's reviewing
food which by the way has to be the best
[__] job ever yeah I'm happy for him
yeah that's a great great job I'm happy
that he got out of MMA yeah seriously
the most underpaying career he's funny
yeah I like watching his [__] no did we
watch the whole like was it the Vegas
restaurant the place in Vegas that he
like blew up I don't think we watched
anything on here no we didn't watch that
video you guys saw that one though right
yeah
um that was a fantastic little story
and I think that restaurant is like
still packed that's sick yeah
eat that pickle
sorry I've seen these around before
I do like pickles and I like Warheads
what but like pause you like Warheads
yeah who didn't like Warheads as a kid
really I didn't I didn't enjoy eating
them oh I loved them I liked them like
they hurt but yeah they're great like I
like sour skittles too that's like
certain like there's a certain
pleasure that comes from like burning
off you know you get that chemical burn
on the inside of your mouth uh yeah I
don't have a pleasure but I know what
you mean well no it's like the sweetness
after us so there's something about it
you know
odds are Skittles
I never liked Warheads
drink some of the juice first
yeah it just tastes like just dill
pickle juice
well I'm not getting any Warhead is what
I'm saying
the comments the way Cody inhales that
pickle
no because like it's the way he inhaled
that it's the way my hands no the wave
just teleported into my hand
it's gone
it's got chemicals yep I got the
chemical burn that's chemicals I can
feel my taste buds getting singed off
right now yeah
oh that's pretty ass
to be honest
that's a horrible collab
what a stupid product
Cody's an entrepreneur now so he knows
what good products are
and that's not a good product
he's out yeah I will not be investing in
Warhead
[Laughter]
extreme sour pickle yeah this is um
come on dude
there's so much [__] here what about the
birdie-bought beans he's the most Bland
thing because my throat is [__] up you
[__] I'm not about to put dill
pickle in my neck
oh
I don't know
yeah it seems like I should eat whatever
is on that board yeah it seems like a
good idea so far he's eaten chemical
pickle dog food and boogers
it was a great start to the day
uh no it was none of those what I just
got
search are these birdie are these
actually birdie Bots
they're what Bean Boozled right
the two that I just had tasted like like
uh pocket lint
not to be confused with belly buttons
no actually yeah it might have been that
and what else we got crickets
I don't think I've ever had a cricket
before
are they
I mean I'll have to work up to that I
think
I will definitely have one
but not right now I don't
after I fed them to people on find that
link I don't think
that's funny
I fed them to people think they'd be
grossed out and everyone would eat them
and go oh
so about easy is like another point I'm
like yeah they're like I'll eat like
five because they're good they're just
nothing they just don't you don't taste
like anything yeah but I think it's the
idea that you're like crunching down on
like a brain but but if there is a
little dried brain in there yeah but
like once you crunch sour cream and
onion once you crunch it I don't think
you can tell
I know but it's the thought I'm saying
yeah but I know
yeah but if if brain tastes like sour
cream and onion all right fine then
yeah you're right yeah it's like yeah
that's pretty [__] good it doesn't
taste like brain it tastes like just
like a Corn Nut yeah
that's pretty good which flavor was that
but there's flavors look at the bottom
of it like near the no sour cream and
onion okay that one's bacon and cheese
oh hell yeah
pretty fire honestly yeah it was crazy
where'd you buy them we just I forgot
where we ordered them but you know
what's funny was we almost ran out
yeah they're just eating them
like I remember someone was like I'll
eat [__] 10 right now and Elena was
like no no no like we won't have any for
the rest of the day and I said oh man we
should open a bar where instead of bar
nuts it's like just crickets yeah yeah
they serve these
that's disgusting but yeah I think
people would go for it they're not that
bad that's crazy no and they kind of
they're like flaky yeah
they're pretty good they're like
whatever by the way go back to the Bean
Boozled chart
I think I think the one I just had was
dirty dishwasher actually
because that's kind of what it tasted
like
liver and onions or cappuccino oh these
[__] are playing with my emotions